shaving causes hair to grow back thicker
shaving doesn't cause hair to grow back
thicker shaving the hair causes it to
grow back feeling coarse thus making it
appear darker and thicker
hey nicotine causes cancer tar and
chemicals in the vapor cause cancer
nicotine is what makes it addictive did
you know the Big Bang was a giant
explosion it was an expansion of outer
space not an explosion coffee is made
from a bean not quite right what we
refer to as coffee beans are actually
seeds goldfish only remember things for
three seconds they can actually remember
things for a pretty long time did you
know that water spins the opposite
direction down the drain and different
hemispheres actually it's the same
everywhere the Coriolis effect which is
what people claim causes the water to
spin in a different direction is too
weak to be visible going down the drain
chameleons change color as a disguise to
match their environment chameleons
change color to communicate with other
chameleons and the camouflage part is
more of a bonus going out in the cold
with a wet head will make you sick in
fact colds are caused by a virus so
people who go outside with wet hair are
no more likely to get sick than those
who don't
did you know Albert Einstein failed at
math when he was young according to
Einstein he mastered differential and
integral calculus before he was 15 a
duck's quack doesn't echo actually a
duck's quack echos pretty well